what's up my babies and welcome to
another episode of congratulations
crazy
[Music]
it's amazing how completely still i stay
when i do that you guys probably think
it's a still screen but it's not it's me
just [ __ ] freezing dude
uh
speaking of freezing i'm cold right now
we had the air conditioner blasting uh
completely blasting in here so we could
keep it cool for a freaking hour and
we're gonna do that dude um i
i
let's well let's just get this out of
the way you can go to chris leah.com get
that merch we've got new life rips
colorways
and that's the [ __ ] that keeps on giving
i keep thinking i'm going to retire that
phrase i'm going to retire that [ __ ] and
then the public the babies the people
who want to enter the log cabin they
speak for themselves and they're like no
no no no we actually want it because
it's fire gear so crystallia.com
if you want to go ahead and support the
show it's great patreon.comcrystalia
i appreciate everyone on my patreon so
much man it helps us keeping the show
going because you know wouldn't do the
show if it weren't for bags and that's
my psa
right unless i'm if i'm not collecting
racks i'm not doing the show you
understand
um
i would still be talking by myself but i
wouldn't be filming it and i wouldn't be
putting it on youtube so willa we love
you on the patreon you can get uh on my
discord and all that [ __ ] uh and that's
it you know and that's it
it's new year it's been new year for a
little bit and uh went into the coffee
bean and tea leaf
and i went to go get a coffee today you
know how i do it i get the four shots
over i over ice because i keep it
absolutely raw and delicious
and i was keeping it around delicious in
there and i
dr i was waiting in line it was about
five people in the coffee bean and tea
leaf your boy's over omicron so he knows
he's got nothing to worry about but i
still got my mask on because everyone
else doesn't know that they got nothing
to worry about and here's the kind of
guy i am
here's the kind of person i am okay
i had the mask on i had to sneeze
so what did i do
i lowered myself all the way down very
close to the ground in the corner i put
my face as far as i could squatting into
the corner took my shirt up over my mask
so now i've got my mask on i've got
another layer of cloth and i'm aiming it
directionally into the [ __ ] corner on
the ground and i'm doing that and i go
at you and it feels like my eyeballs are
gonna pop out that's how hard i sneeze
but i tried to keep it nice for
everybody because here's the thing i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't care i know
i'm good
i know i'm good with omicron i know i've
had i know i can't get it dude i'm
practically the healthiest dude on the
planet at this point okay
i mean i'm a guy
who now has had omicron who's over
omicron
that now gets his his meals delivered
i mean i'm healthy dude i'm never
talking about postmates anymore i
leveled up
dude i got a guy named chef mike
chef mike he makes my [ __ ] brings it
here i heat it up i'm eating [ __ ] like
salmon dude so i'm healthy as [ __ ]
okay
your boy goes by go this is me looking
at pizza bye bye this is me looking at
burgers i'll catch you maybe once a week
i mean burgers are practically my mom at
this point i see him once a week see you
later
okay but i'm the healthiest [ __ ]
but why do i do that why do i go and dip
out into the [ __ ] bottom corner of
coffee bean with two with cloth over me
and a mask over me if i need to sneeze
why do i do that because if i run
outside i'm a [ __ ] and i lose my place
in line but i'm working with people dude
i work with people
and i don't know how cuck everyone is in
that place
i don't know how how liberal everyone is
in that area
but i'm easy going dude
[Laughter]
so i did that for everyone else so if
you're in that coffee bean and you saw
me duck down and do a crazy sneeze it
wasn't for me it was for you
and if you didn't think i needed to do
that then that's fine but i did it for
you anyway
and i wanted to get that out of the way
because i felt a little bit cuck doing
it i'm going to be in oxnard california
uh um
[Music]
uh what do you call it uh in uh 15 the
14th and 15th and 16th we've got tickets
at crystallia.com and go to chrisley.com
i'm going to be in san diego two weeks
after that i think we got to put that on
my website it'll be on my website by the
time this episode comes out but uh i
gotta be playing the laugh factory in
san diego down there uh love the laugh
factory um and um
yeah so it's been new years for what now
two weeks one week two weeks two weeks
and um
bro i came out i play i was playing
video games by the way i'll get into it
because i love the [ __ ] video i love
been really getting into this video game
but
i was playing video games on my twitch
actually i don't think i was on twitch
your boy was off twitch playing video
games so that's how you know he's a
gamer at this point i didn't even have
headphones on i was just flailing around
being spider-man buy my lonesome calvin
would come in i'd be like who's that
he'd be like my my man that's what he
says for spider-man and then he'd walk
out he'd get bored and walk out
and i'm doing all sort of i get [ __ ]
nice with the swings i get [ __ ] fancy
with it you know i'm just in between
building like just like just it's like
butter do it it's like in between toast
dude i'm going really nice i hit
triangle i do flips man i rotate i get
my xp
skyrocketing dude
right
i'm swinging under bad dude's leg coming
them out and from the other side and
just [ __ ] throwing webs in their
faces dude
but that's just the kind of [ __ ]
playing i do it i get real nice with it
when i'm in the zone you know and i'm
doing that and all of a sudden i hear
[ __ ]
the worst and i'm not even gonna explain
who it was or anything more than this
but
the worst
song from nashville period and that
means what it means okay that's what i
hear outside
the worst the outside of the room the
worst song from nashville period
probably somebody named chase sings it
do you know what i mean
every ninth country star is chase
somebody
with a [ __ ] some kind of [ __ ] beard
and oh for sure either a flannel or an
army green button down and he's just
rocking out
a good old boy just rocking out and i'm
like what is this [ __ ] it's new year's
eve i walk out and i look and it's him
whoever a chase guy is probably and then
another chick who's who's just singing
with them and i'm just like what is this
and kristin says oh it's the new year's
eve thing we're watching it because it's
new year's eve so my question then is
why is it new year's eve programming
so [ __ ] terrible
okay
you go to channel 4 you go to channel 7
you go to channel 11 whatever channel
you've got some cuck in a suit
well let's check in they're always
checking in with somebody
like like they're that doesn't do news
don't ever check in
with [ __ ]
katy perry you don't have to check in
with smokey [ __ ] robinson
check in
with only a news guy
well let's check in and see let's check
in on over to [ __ ]
let's go see what check let's go check
in
let's go check into smokey robinson
we're going to check in with usher let's
check in
with a guy who's got a new hot single
he's got a green he's got an army button
down his name is chase
country boy let's check in hey y'all
let's chase country boy we're out here
2021 was a tough one let's move on to
2022.
i'm in the back of my car right
country songs get so goddamn specific
cause when we were in the back of my car
in the backseat at the [ __ ] back
target parking lot we barbecue and the
grits is on your thing and you fell and
[ __ ] slipped in the puddle and then
we just [ __ ] looked at each other
dude it's so goddamn specific hey guy
make it vaguer
hey chase
use innuendos
country music is just and my hat was
crooked in the [ __ ] back of the bar
and the boots is clanking and
using innuendo
right
my old t-shirt how many [ __ ] it's just
dude emote
your mommy emoji shirt in the back of
themselves
[Laughter]
can't [ __ ]
help themselves and we slipped in the
puddle and we're laughing them times
better when they're laying on it
again laying on them
and we're watching this [ __ ] goddamn
thing and we change it to channel seven
and hi it's ryan seacrest
i have the worst job alive ryan seacrest
i'm here i'm four foot eight and i would
like you to know that uh here we are
catching up we're catching up and we're
checking in that's what we're doing
we're catching up and checking in and
you recognize me from
hamburrican idol
that's what he says every time he says
american idol you tell me he says
american instead of hamburgen and i'll
suck your dick how about that
if you don't have one go get one i'll
suck it straight up he says hamburrican
idol and that's that
i'm ryan seacrest we're here we're about
to check in with [ __ ]
you know we're about to check in with
smokey robinson hey what's up man that's
smokey robinson
hey we're here we're freezing i took us
off on a [ __ ] dude new year's eve
programming sucks
it sucks it sucks
so bad and then people would be like
dave what was the guys dave clark was
that his name clark
dick clark
that [ __ ] name you know dick clark
and then it's how about this it sucked
then too we just didn't have the
internet
we just evolved it just sucked dude
watching that [ __ ] and she was like but
it gets into the spirit and every
channel you change it's a louder chase
country boy just [ __ ] and the back of
the bar
it started it started out on channel two
and if we were slipping puddle and we
went back in the barn my hat was crooked
and you remind me of my old t-shirt
turn the channel forward and we're
slipping the bar on the back in the
t-shirt and you remind me of this vest
that i used to wire a different chase
dog turn on channel seven hey you remind
me of the [ __ ] hat that's crooked in
the slips in the back of the castle oil
hi we're here checking in with all the
chases
it was so it's so bad dude new year's
eve
new year's eve is [ __ ] so amateur
dude and people go out and they're just
standing like this in the goddamn times
square just saying just looking up
hurting their [ __ ] [ __ ] necks
looking at goddamn mariah carey or some
[ __ ]
or [ __ ] jason derulo or [ __ ] oh
look it's that oh
you can't stay home
we got tvs stay the [ __ ] home it's
easier
hi i'm ryan seacrest the only job worse
than mine is hooker
the only job worse than hi i'm ryan
seacrest the only job worth all i do is
say what people tell me to say that's
all i do
i just say what everyone tells me to say
my job is the worst
unless you're a hooker that only does
anal
we're gonna check in with katy perry
just unreal dude
i really drill these jokes to the ground
huh but that's what we do
i don't give a [ __ ] dude
and then they'll do and it'll be like
nah
it'll be like
ten
nine and i'm always always just in my
head hurry up
i don't i want the seconds to go fast
it's so i have so much anxiety dude
watching the ball drop how are dude this
is practically caveman [ __ ]
we're evolved past this we need to ca
we're sitting there watching a ball drop
like it's 1987.
like there's no [ __ ] oculus vr [ __ ]
going and we're just
at nine eight and and my girl and
[ __ ] we had two three people over and
they were we were just whole everyone
was holding each other dude i don't want
to be touching anyone in the new year
i want to be do my dream honestly and
nobody's ever let me get away with this
because i've always had a girlfriend on
new year's eve
and my dream my dream and i mean this is
to [ __ ] 10 45 at 10 45 p.m to just
start driving just you know where you
know where
ask me where so you be in the car right
now or your cubicle or wherever you are
and your talk and you're listening to me
right this is crystalia and let's have a
conversation let's have an actual
conversation hey guy listen to me i want
you to say out loud where are you going
where are you going to go at 10 40.
where are you going to start driving at
10 45 i'll give you time to say that so
go ahead say that and then i'll answer
it so here we go go ahead say that
i don't know
that's my answer dude that's my answer
ah
out around
and guess where i go
i go where the lights get dimmer the
lights get smaller i'm out in the middle
of nowhere
by [ __ ] 11 45
i drive an hour and 15 minutes dude
i'm far away from everything i can't
even get a signal and maybe
[ __ ] maybe i start at [ __ ] 9 15. i
go far i go way past
barstow i'm in [ __ ] lubbock like i'm
past that [ __ ] you know
i start maybe i start at six dude
i could be in arizona or [ __ ] spokane
you don't have any idea
never said spokane in this whole podcast
said it twice in this episode
and um yeah dude
and then i get and then i try to listen
i try to listen for the countdown and i
can't hear it dude i can't hear it and i
don't look at my watch and i don't look
at my phone and i just guess i guess
when the new year happens and i'm
touching nobody and there's no animals
around me maybe there's a bug where i
gotta go like that with and that's it
dude that's my dream and then i guess
when i can maybe drive back
i don't wanna know we're past this [ __ ]
bro i've evolved man
i've evolved past new year's eve get me
neural link
um
because the other thing is what
what are you around people you love like
a [ __ ] you know what i mean
five
four
three are you one of those guys
dude are you one of those guys
four
three
are you one of those guys just getting
louder and louder do you start too loud
sometimes and then you gotta go back
down right
like the goal is to do ten no you start
soft enough but people get nuts and they
get [ __ ] too excited ten don't start
there you're [ __ ] by five
right you gotta go
ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
you're gonna start off the new year like
a [ __ ] you can't you don't know your
octaves
that's how the year's gonna go for you
start low end with what happened
those [ __ ] things
with the [ __ ] these things that
[Music]
oh we haven't evolved past that dude
ryan seacrest is a [ __ ] one of these
things
he's the human form of the [ __ ]
i don't even know what that is it's a
noisemaker of course but i don't know
what it is specifically and i will never
know and you buy those
in packs
if people buy them in packs dude
they buy they'll buy like a 12 pack of
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] all that dude
no
no and i'm not a curmudgeon dude and i
get it i know i know the older i get
you're like well that's the old guy but
it's that's who i've been bro
that's who i've been
people are like you're a young larry
david with the how you're bitching at
everyone no way dude i'm the
[ __ ] i'm i'm larry david if he
puts the mask on dude uh smoking that's
me man
i'm the hulk
bro
not with the avengers dude the avengers
are all screaming out five four you got
iron man
two
uh hulk the lonely hulk dude
outside of lubbock
guessing when the ball drops
feeling when the new year happens dude
i'm going to tell you right now y'all
are some [ __ ] if you do the countdown
period i'll never do that i'll never do
the countdown
you don't tell me when to count down
uh anyway dude that's what's up that's
what i've been trying it that's what
i've been trying to [ __ ] get at this
whole time that i've been alive
and i figured it out
[Music]
shipping delays supply shortages
holiday demand last year was a mess all
right we all know it
now you're ringing in the new year with
impatient customers returns and
expensive shipping rates i get it trust
me i run my own company it's time to
switch to a shipping solution that can
handle it all painlessly i use it ship
station
why would you use anything but ship
station i'm telling you
the easiest and most convenient choice
for e-commerce sellers import orders
from any sales channel
ship using any carrier with deeply
discounted rates
automate just about any shipping cast
and i'm not stopping now in 2022 i'm
ready to take my merch to the next level
with ship station trust me you know i'm
always taking it to the next level well
i'm doing it with ship station
save time by funneling
all your orders into one simple
interface no matter where you're selling
manage every order amazon ebay etsy or
your own website any from anywhere even
your phone it's so easy save money when
you compare carrier options and choose
the best shipping solution every single
time
ship station works with every carrier
and you can always find the best fit for
you i'm telling you it's so easy save
your sanity knowing your orders are
handled and you're getting the best
rates
make shipping
easy
and make it the easy part of having an
online store
you have bigger ideas to think about
it's already uh
don't make it more difficult this saves
time it makes it so much easier uh ship
more in less time with shipstation use
my offer code congrats to get a 60 day
free trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in congrats ship
station make ship happen
[Music]
so that's great dude how about
richard karn and the tweet
of the century
and i know twitter's only been around
since 2009
but the tweet
of the century richard karn was the guy
who had the tv show in the tv show home
improvement which is
so
[ __ ] awesome to be famous that way
to be famous as a guy who's a famous guy
who has a tv show
about
making homes
is amazing
that's who he is
maybe he's been in other things
i have no idea but he's the guy from
home improvement that was buddies with
tim allen and he was great in home
improvement and he's got a great face
he has a twitter because he's somebody
and the dude put out um
a tweet so
so hot
i mean this tweet is so high it's the
tweet of the century it's so hot
that satan goes can you turn on the air
conditioning like it's so hot
it's so
hot that bellzebub is like i gotta maybe
move this is getting old
right
i mean
this is what he says
in the tweet
bro this is the most [ __ ] when i saw
this [ __ ]
when i saw this [ __ ]
ah
i sat i honestly sat down i was standing
up i saw this and i sat down i'm gonna
tell you what it is okay
he writes
this is the tweet of the goddamn century
dude you should hope to do twitter like
this
he writes
i've thought long and hard about
[Laughter]
he wrote i've thought long and hard
about nfts and i've decided it's not
something i need to do
and then he put prayer hands
and a hearts emoji
and leveled it up with a picture of him
sitting in a booth
[Music]
dude
how do you get
so boss
so ceo
the guy
goes like this
tony soprano move over
the guy in one tweet
goes like this
lucky luciano excuse me
in one [ __ ] tweet dude
he goes knucky thompson
can i sit there
excuse me al capone didn't see you there
he's the boss now
he goes hey springsteen can i strum a
little bit
this guy is the most angst he goes
he goes easy who
doctor who
n double j why
that's the most boss gangster tweet dude
and he's got a rolex on and his sleeves
are rolled up and he's got wood paneling
behind them course and the thomas
kincaid paid knock
is that the guy's name
who cares you know what i'm talking
about it's a lot of green in it dude the
guy's killing it who took the pick he's
got the nicest teeth
dude i cannot [ __ ] believe he wrote
i've thought long and hard about nfts
and i've decided it's not something i
need to do to even say that out
you know what
to even have a brain that constructs
that sentence
inside of you
would make tony soprano go oh and move
over a little bit
but the guy not only constructed it in
his brain
he's
he didn't even say it out loud which
would have been enough for
for lucky luciano
to skim to to let richard karn skim a
lil off the top
right just just saying it
would have let al capone be like well
this guy is actually one of the guys
that we might have to deal with someday
right to just to just say but this guy
not only wrote it down
which which maybe would have let which
maybe would have made lucky thompson
sweat right if he walked in the door but
this guy
tweeted it for the world to see and not
only that
posted it with a picture of him with
some wood paneling behind it now that
is the most [ __ ] gangster [ __ ]
and when i tell you i strive to be a
[ __ ] like this dude when i tell
you you think that this podcast is jokes
yes what i'm describing is always in a
funny way but this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
serious i strive to be somebody like
this
i know and the [ __ ] are out
here trying to deal with the coronavirus
and there's this [ __ ] going on dude i
swear to god this should be the number
one [ __ ] thing on time magazine dude
enough of this omicron delta [ __ ]
man this dude's sitting pretty think
expressing how he's not gonna
[Laughter]
not like long and hard you know about
nfts wow that's some gangster-ass [ __ ]
dude
you got a fan now bro i gotta follow him
on instagram i don't do twitter but
jason derulo got into hugh got in a
fight he threw his
he threw his hands man loses it in vegas
fights guys who call him usher
it's funny to uh fight somebody because
they call you someone who's more
successful
like you know
i get it if they were calling him
screech from saved by the bell
or [ __ ] uh you know
it's not like they're calling them
[ __ ] uh
who's the b2k guy
god what a terrible name for a group b2k
you know
b2k such a flash in the pan that's like
calling them the [ __ ] razor scooters
that's the most the [ __ ]
that's the most passe [ __ ] now b2k
um
so richard so richard khan is is the
boss and then uh jason derulo got in a
fight
let's let these people get the best of
them we got it right here it's on tmz
which is of course tmz is always [ __ ]
finding me at coffee shops and [ __ ] with
the cameras in my face hey crystalia so
what do you think about this and i'm
like hey you guys tried to bury me
what's going on
i ain't got no i ain't got no
[ __ ] friends
um
so this is what happened
let's watch this video
that's so annoying
hey yo why slap him dog hey yo where are
you slap him hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
slap him why are you slapping well
called him usher
called him usher and went berserk
wow wow he came wow he came through hard
he's like a juggernaut
you think this is honestly because he's
still mad at cats
wow he [ __ ] really he knocks him too
hard too wow that's great that guy all
tough so far away oh we [ __ ] hit him
hard dude
dude don't [ __ ] with dancers man for
real
they can [ __ ] if they can skate
around a [ __ ] wood floor with no
uh skates on they could move around like
that with no roller blades
man you don't want to tussle with them
for real
but that would be that's like crazy to
be some somebody who's more successful
to be that mad must have been something
else going on he must still have some
cat stuff going for real like why do the
movie get what if what if when he threw
the punch you heard very quietly
what do the movie cats
unreal
oh i [ __ ] forgot to eat this i wanted
to try dude it's our first taste test
here at uh congratulations
i talked about uh on one of the
um
i think it was one of the patreon
episodes i talked about um dj khaled and
how he's doing a another wing
um
what do you call it another wing uh
food for for
he's partnering with postmates and it's
just a delivery thing cool there's a
hair on it great um and um
he'd uh you know what that's something i
don't give a [ __ ] about this is honestly
i'm telling you the truth the second
hair i've gotten in a meal today i don't
care i take it i pull it off i don't
sometimes they go in my you know how
often you get hair in your mouth a lot i
do a lot honestly because it's always in
the food you know if you're eating out
and doing the [ __ ] i get it in and i
just use it i take it out i peel it out
and i try to get in between my teeth to
floss it i don't give a [ __ ]
hey it's hair dude
i ain't no [ __ ] i'm no mark ass [ __ ]
when it comes to that so um so we got
two of these uh another wings because i
wanted to try them now i'm not a wing
guy okay and i'm gonna be honest with
this [ __ ] all right
but uh this is um dj khaled's another
wing i'm gonna try it for you guys you
can get this on postmates and i'm not
i'm not this is not i'm not you well i
don't know maybe this will be horrible
but i'm not trying to be like you know
i'm not endorsing [ __ ]
that's the bonus one
that one's really good you didn't like
it
well the bonus one is ridiculously good
okay
let's watch it livestock sit down
and then this one is the one with the
bone in it
no
the boneless one is good wow we have
complete one fire like the other one wow
that one's spicy huh the bone the one
with the bone in it i like that
i like [ __ ] with a little kick in it i
like when i get you right here i like it
when it gets you here when it gets you
right here
but that's it dude nothing a little bit
of four shots of americano can take care
of
um
yeah that was actually
that boneless one's good he didn't like
it but whatever dude
you got to eat this [ __ ] sometimes no
matter what the liver king says
the liver king eats [ __ ] legitimately
he ate a pine cone did you see him he
ate a pine cone he ate a pine cone hey
guy you're gonna die early and that's
fine uh you did it to yourself why does
he do [ __ ] like this though
this is a post he did a day ago
the liver king on instagram i talked
about in my last episode anyone who
knows liver king knows that i don't stop
until a job is done
yeah okay sure you ate a pine cone you
know
that goes for everything completing the
super barbarian
spreading the ancestral message wow i
can't even imagine what that is and even
crushing a car with one badass tank okay
i'm the proud driver of oh i'm liver
king i'm the proud driver of every
single outcome in my life why not this
too
and then he
never king here i'm getting ready to run
over a car why because i'm liverpool i
can't stop saying liver king you know
liver king here why liver king liver
king gonna drive over a liver king tank
so unnecessary
driving over a [ __ ]
what is that a cabriolet
unbelievable i had this whole family in
the tank too dude
what's up wow first comment under this
is i made 300 000 with profit with
robert unbelievable dude
dude what is the deal
with guys like this
truly
honestly
eat bone marrow
i mean the guy [ __ ] sucked fish balls
i watched him suck a fish dick on the
thing he ate a pine cone
like just okay
but what is it about like
what is i don't here's what i here's
what i don't here's what i never liked
you know
when you can look at someone and just
know what they're all about do you know
what i'm talking about
like
and i don't even if you're about good
[ __ ]
i don't want to know
like how come you don't have some sense
of mystery about you guy i get social
media exposes us all right
but like
dude
if you lined up
150 people
and liver king was one of them and you
asked me hey which is the one that goes
by liver king and drives over cars with
a tank
i know is this guy
what is it like
there is no doubt like i know everybody
listens to him but you'd never be like i
wonder if that guy listens to joe rogan
you know he does
you know what is it with the guy
that needs to do all the guy [ __ ]
what is that
this guy could
not have had a good childhood there's
just no way
there's no [ __ ] way
a guy looks like a [ __ ] ninja turtle
what is it about a guy that needs to do
all the guys [ __ ] it's so weird bro
but he has so many look like just
opposing a picture posing with a spear
you know
hey guy there's the internet
why are we still doing this is the whole
thing evolve dude
stop saying new year new me and living
the same life
life over and over if you truly seek to
restore the highest version of yourself
you'll be willing to take massive action
you won't make excuses for yourself
you'll start today
now now son hold now son and daughter
hold these machine guns we have to pose
for instagram like dude this is the life
like woody
the nine ancestral tenants are a simple
elegant framework for a way of living
that sustained our ancestors for
thousands of years wow
nah bro there's tv
nah there's tv
you don't ever need to be like our ances
people are just heavy on the ancestor
[ __ ] i'm just like i'm out
yeah our ancestors have been using uh
times change i'm out there's tv we got
best buy you know my ancestors thought
of best buy nothing
there's new [ __ ] out now
yeah but our ancestors have been doing
it's really been working it's been
working for thousands of years and
you're gonna come along and change it no
change changed it
no i'm not gonna do [ __ ] but there's
[ __ ] neuralink coming up
i gotta eat bone marrow what are you
talking about there's [ __ ] posts
postmates will deliver my [ __ ] i'm my
own king how about that
i can press a button and they'll deliver
a [ __ ] cheeseburger
that makes my midsection of my brain
do jism
okay
i'm gonna we gotta well you know yoga
all right dude oh okay
oh yeah
oh
yoga
because they've been studying it for oh
really okay
yoga then
burger
when people used to tell me oh you gotta
go on go that's the whole thing uh you
know and i do think that you should
unplug sometimes but god damn
when people think camping is gonna save
their [ __ ] life you know
it's like go kiss yourself man
can't you they think that sitting near a
[ __ ] river is just gonna
clear up oh and i just feel so it's like
but sometimes you need to detox and they
just they're in tulum
like that wasn't created too by
billionaires
this is the it's always chicks that do
it too and chicks got dudes doing it now
because they're trying to get [ __ ]
you got [ __ ] and dockers like
sometimes it's good to unplug man you're
just saying what the [ __ ] girl you
want to sleep with this saying
chick's got fantastic ideas man
they really do we gotta unplug because
we gotta get back to our dude i'm out of
here man i got a microwave close to me
i'm always near a microwave
too low
[Music]
we're reheating in this [ __ ]
it's just like dude
gonna sit near a creek and figure out
all the [ __ ] nah dude nah nah nah
that's not how it works just maybe don't
look at your phone for a
day you don't need to get in the kayak
um
anyway dude it's pretty [ __ ] jason
derulo hit that guy
but it is what it is
there's so many things that just don't
need to be something anymore you know
it's like
it's like we're done with it like why
are why is anybody ever holding a spear
like liver king is holding a spear like
dude there's ak-47s
um
here's another one why
why
does the british royal guard
exist still oh because of tradition
you know how much tradition sucks god
damn i really feel like an old
curmudgeon i'm not though this has
always been how tradition
is one of the top
things
that leads to
war and i don't say that lightly
tradition
is
bad
things change
traditions
are bad for us
period white black asian indian
jewish
family
traditions
just ruin [ __ ] because then you're
locked in a way of thinking i got to do
it this way and then well what happens
when i finally there's offspring that
doesn't want to do the tradition well
then now we're at each other aren't we
now we're at each other aren't we and
when does that lead to a [ __ ] war
yeah okay that's a huge jump but every
step is terrifying
we just don't realize it
the british royal guard with their
[ __ ] microphone hats
they're such [ __ ] dude
oh whoa what are you protecting now they
ran over a child you know
they marched over a child okay we're
done after that they should have just
been like oh well we're completely out
tight aren't we oh yes
they're mascots now look at this
don't get in their way on
oh wow
that was really [ __ ]
actually
wow
so [ __ ] dick
just marched over that child you better
pray that child's white
um
for real dude if it's not
that's it if that's it the [ __ ] royal
guard is
coming
tumbling down dude you better
hope that that melanin isn't dark you
better hope
you better hope that you just need
powder in the face
cause i'll tell you right now if that
person even got a tan this summer
you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] the british guard's coming
tumbling down
a british card you tumbling
dude
people just somebody said people justify
a guard stepping on a child as being the
child's fault man if a kid jumps in
front of your duty is to you know as a
human being not hurt them
he won't lose his job by going around
the kid
um
oh this guy writes in a normal setup yes
not in drill that mother of his was
irresponsible she should
made her sure her son was not in the way
of the guard dude hey no don't have the
guard
and also don't march like that you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
walk hey
put on a base hey put on a ball cap and
walk
walk to a different job nobody's
attacking your goddamn castle you know
what you are you're a guy that can't
laugh oh you're the most unfun useless
person
alive hey what's your job
standing and not laughing
hey what's your job standing
and having no countenance
you're worse than a guy who only works
out and doesn't apply his muscles for
anything but the gym
hey royal guard you know what you don't
exist anymore in my head you don't exist
if i see anyone that is a royal guard
member
[Laughter]
in my life i go like this from now on i
go like this why is that guy wearing all
that
i don't know anymore
i don't even know anymore
that's where i'm at they met him black
me with that [ __ ]
dude tommy lee jones came up to me look
right here
and then i see the royal guard why is
that guy wearing that
that's what i do
wow people are saying mother's fault
mother's fault a
times change i love how the [ __ ] asb
news
asb military news tweeted it
unbelievable
breaking military news
with you know hey everything has a
twitter huh
breaking military news with focus on
nato russia middle east
dude it has 47.6 000 followers who the
[ __ ] is following military new dude i'll
tell you right now man there's just too
many [ __ ] people out there
and not enough people like richard karn
i've decided i've thought long and hard
about nfts and i've decided it's not
something i need to do
on
[ __ ] real
defend the queen
oh hey there's a nine-year-old let me
stomp all over him queen
you're a you're a [ __ ] you're a br
you're a tourist attraction that's what
you are you're a bridge
that's what you are
you're a [ __ ] you're one of those red
phone booths
you're big ben but smaller with a
raccoon on your head
god you suck
wow
hard hitting [ __ ] man my baby's hard
hitting [ __ ] and this is exactly the
kind of stuff that this cult was founded
on sitting in the tall grass talking
about how [ __ ] the royal british guard
is do it that is what we do and you guys
are out there want to listen to npr make
another podcast popular that's fine
share spread the word of the cult
this is what's important
no hyperbole
man crystallia.com for tickets i'm
starting to do the road
got two dates coming up
drinking all respectful
um hmm
sign up for the second youtube channel
crystallia uh uh more cr what a [ __ ]
more just type in more crystalline click
on that whatever the [ __ ]
um
i've been watching uh boardwalk empire
dude
that's why i talked about nucky thompson
dude boardwalk empire's so good man and
i'm on season i'm still watching gamora
i usually don't do this man i usually
don't watch two things at once i'm
watching gamora i'm watching uh
uh what's the the the one i just said
boardwalk empire and i'm watching dexter
dude new blood or whatever it's called
and um i never have been watching three
shows at once
my [ __ ] you know how i am i'm an addict
i'm a straight up addict
i do addict behavior when i see
something i watch it to the end i watch
it [ __ ] full throttle to the end i
start with episode one and i end with
episode end dude and kristen is like can
we just and i said you said you wanted
to start watching this three days ago
let's start season five
come on and she's like but can we just
for a little bit just and i say no dude
i'm full throttle baby
so i started watching boardwalk and park
and she's like what about this one
because you know chicks love [ __ ]
[ __ ] about period pieces you know they
love perry like if you put dude
you put a show on
if they're dressed in outfits that
aren't in fashion anymore chicks are all
in dude how many chicks believe that
they really should have been alive in
the 19th that's just my era the 1920s
you know if i could pick one one decade
that i could it would be the 19th oh
really you don't like voting
you like getting smacked around by a
large popular you like you know what i
mean
and uh
so we started watching boardwalk empire
and i'm like immediately i'm like holy
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is good
like i've got this for some reason it
doesn't come up in like the greatest
shows of all time bye bye surveys bye
bye critics
there is
in no world is boardwalk empire not one
of the greatest tv shows of all time in
no world it's so good dude
better than the wire better than the
wire sopranos it's a lot like sopranos
sopranos is [ __ ] amazing um breaking
bad is probably the number one show ever
but like
i don't know man boardwalk empire is
amazing dude
amazing why is it not
you know
anyway i'm watching it i'm on season i
don't know what season i'm on but i'm
watching it
and uh
i like it all except for uh i'm like
it's always weird to me to see steve
buscemi in anything that's not where
he's not just playing like a [ __ ]
bowler or something
and he just plays like this boss that
like kind of throws guys around and i'm
just like i don't know and my brother's
like just wait
he's the best just wait so i'm like i
don't wait i'll wait
i'm waiting
i trust my brother's [ __ ] you know
what i mean thing
um
[Music]
where are we at here an hour we'll do a
little more do we have miss connections
or no
oh we did them okay let's do miss
connections then [ __ ] it
um
are they under this [ __ ] nft's thing
oh wow here we go yep got him hey guys
it's time for miss connections
looking to reconnect a micro sized
latino uh small package with my
girlfriends uh okay not a sentence
looking to here's the body of it
looking to reconnect with a husky big
guy with small little package why is
small
it it's like instead of an a they have a
four in it like it's a bad word
we don't want to get flagged
and still and says little package in it
which is definitely more direct
looking to reconnect with a husky big
guy with a small little package
so you want a big husky guy with a
little dick i've never heard anyone ever
want that
i know there's kinks for everyone but
you want a big guy with a little dick
okay
for you to meet one of my girlfriends if
you have a small piece wow [ __ ] in in
the same sentence
also mentions small piece and little
package okay we get it guy looking for
short package only jesus christ that's i
mean how small you want this guy's dick
micro size
wow okay i get the kink now
i mean dude how many to again hit me up
especially if you're a chubby stocky
gordo with a little package eh
how many times does this guy have a
[ __ ] different nine times he's
talking about how the guy's penis needs
to be little little hey man we get it
and you know there's still going to be
[ __ ] that hit him up what if
like okay like so it looks small if it's
no dude it needs to practically go
inside you need to pretty much be
it has to
be a [ __ ]
it has to go inside
dude let me just read this whole thing
let's count how many times it it is with
the [ __ ] thing that he says the thing
looking to reconnect a micro size latino
small package with my girlfriend that's
two in the title alone all right then
looking to reconnect with a husky big
guy with a small little package that's
three for you to meet one of my
girlfriends if you have a small piece
that's four looking for short package
only five micro size hit me up
especially if you are a chubby stocky
gordo with a little package dude seven
times in two sentences he talks about
how the guy needs to have a little [ __ ]
hey your dad died early
and if you respond to this your dad died
with him
you know this is the most and it says it
but this is the most do not contact me
with unsolicited services or offers
because no [ __ ] dude well i actually
have a medium-sized dick no thanks i
need it to be a little package small
package small piece short package micro
sized and you gotta be latino
unreal dude these guys
unreal and smell
and spell small with a four
here's another one retired and missing
my friend sad
you used to stop by before covet 19. i
am still here on my knees
get up
i am still here on my knees please feel
free to leave your mask on i miss your
stop and go
guy needs to work on his uh innuendo
i miss you stop and go
wow imagine calling
sex
stop and go
oh baby
i know we've had a lot of issues lately
but
would i be remiss if i didn't mention
i'd love some stop and go with you at
this point
god tonight
stop and go just text imagine if i just
texted kristen stop and go question mark
she'd say huh
uh you used to be you used to stop by
before covet 19. i am still here on my
knees wow bleeding for sure please feel
free to leave your mask on feel free
wow
what do they call it the [ __ ] uh the
[ __ ] thing feel free
um
here's another one drinking lemonade oh
i wonder what this is really
about
chub latino dude anytime they write chub
i'm just i'm done you know what i mean
chub
the least sexy
second descending hey chub come on over
and suck my [ __ ]
so
condescending hey chub
chub latino guy here very thirsty here
a poem
i love to drink a man's lemonade
straight from the tap
why don't you just tweet i drink piss
any takers like we get it you know what
is this [ __ ] misc
chubbly wow these are good ones chub
latino guy here very thirsty here i love
to drink a man's lemonade straight from
the tap it is so much fun and love
making a man happy by slurping his tap
real good
slurping his tap
very chill person here wow
i'd like to i'd love to drink your your
piss very chill i'm very chill though
man if you're not into it all good
just if you wanna very chill person here
you be too let's have some fun just have
plenty of lemonade for me to drink
wow oh this guy put his phone number on
i should call
man
i shouldn't call though
uh in the neighborhood
lancaster i'm a guy looking for new
friends in the neighborhood i just moved
to the area i don't know anyone that's
it so sad no innuendo dude i mean way
sadder to just be like
hey
hey what's up i'm in lancaster anybody
want to have a friend
wow just got sad doing even doing that
here's another one fun-filled time i'm a
77 years old gay man looking for gay
male with experienced small hands what's
up with this [ __ ]
everyone wants [ __ ] to be small nowadays
huh
uh experienced small hands who can host
and lives in my area for some fun-filled
time no endless emails
not on here to chat
fun-filled you know that there isn't a
more 77-year-old thing to say than
fun-filled time
any senior ladies like easy hiking san
gabriel are you a senior lady interested
in doing some easy hiking contact me i
mean it's boring
don't people don't have friends huh
here's another one lost my girlfriend
covina 55 year old lost my young
girlfriend still looking for her in the
walmart send me a message with pic if
you think you're her oh wow okay well
there's a murder case or the guy just
got can't can't understand that she left
him
wow
damn imagine
both ways imagine you thought
that your girl
left you
imagine being so imagine your girl
imagine thinking your girl got taken
when really she just left you like how
beta that is and then how boss player it
is
to think she got murdered just because
she left you
that's the level i want to be on that's
the level that [ __ ] what's his name
the guy from home improvement is on
to just be to be like yeah dude i think
my girl i think my girl got murdered oh
really why dude i haven't seen her in
forever
really yeah and whoever murderer took
her furniture too
wow
she didn't leave you
what
huh
no i've thought long and hard about this
and i decided that that's not something
that somebody's going to do to me
um
here's another one cd plumber for big
pipes van nuys
thick
xd plumber what's that
we don't know here at congratulations
studios
looking for young fat pipes to drain
with my very tight bottom tool wow hey
[ __ ]
craigslist get on this one and ban this
guy you know it's very simple it's very
easy
they don't you can't say suck my dick
but you can say
looking for young fat pipes to drain
with my very tight bottom tool
if you just left out tooled you'd get
banned you know
just added the word tool and it's fine
hey man hey
guy here
30 years old would love it if you came
by and used your mouth tool on my [ __ ]
tool
would love it if you used your your anus
your anus wrench on my [ __ ]
on my [ __ ] screwdriver
tool
let's have gay tool sex
oh [ __ ]
do you have a level and [ __ ]
[ __ ] man how funny were these these were
great
are you adding another one no okay um
[ __ ] well that's that man we had a good
time dude today and congratulations
congratulations
um
i got dates crystalia.com san diego and
oxnard um they're on my website uh and
you can go get the new life rips
colorway crystallia.com you keep asking
for it so we made more um
well that's the end of the episode here
on youtube if you want the rest of the
episode the uncut version with no ads no
commercials anything go on over to our
patreon that's patreon.comchrisdelia
and you get an episode an extra episode
a month you get uh our other show review
mode you get other behind-the-scenes
stuff and uh
access to our discord where we chat and
we have a lot watchalongs for every
episode um and that's all for six
dollars a month crystallia.com
slash i'm sorry uh we'll go there and
get it but it's patreon.comcrystalia
thank you very much
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
everyone's like why is your beard all
weird